des grands médias meanstream je précise
ils ont ils s'occupent aussi déconnectée
de ses électeurs et surtout de cette
insurrection populaire des français qui
n'ont pas les voter parce que c'est un
acte politique
il n'était pas à la plage de france et
ils ne vont pas voter parce qu'ils ne
veulent plus voter et participer à ce
cap les marcel gaucher ce théâtre des
ombres
voilà où on en est ce soir et je le
redis c'est un séisme politique
[Musique]
les deux parties qu'on nous vend pour la
fiche de 2022 le rn et la république en
marche ils ont été balayés
ils t'ont des frais mauvais score la
république en marche encore pire que
leur assemblée nationale et pourtant il
faudrait que 2022 ce soit et même macron
face à marine le pen
visiblement non c'est parce que
demandent les hardes électeurs se
déplacent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]